ich habe mein gesamtes Erspartes in eine
Idee gesteckt und ein Startup gegründet
ohne zu wissen ob daraus überhaupt etwas
werden kann am Ende hat uns genau diese
Idee zum erfolgreichsten Launch
Deutschlands jemals dii Monate ist der
Release von savid nun her und nahezu
unter jedem Video wollt ihr wissen wann
endlich ein Update kommt wie es um die
App steht vor allem wie es weitergeht in
diesem Video erwarten euch alle Stories
aus dem Leben mit einem jungen
Unternehmen den ersten drei Monaten
eines Startups und natürlich alle Zahlen
Daten und Fakten und vor allem
unglaublich viel Cashback ihr in den
ersten drei Monaten mit Savage sparen
konntet und damit herzlich Willkommen zu
Folge 6 von
St ach ja und gleichzeitig gibt's Infos
zu neuen Features denn genau in dem
Moment in dem ihr dieses Video schaut
ist ein neues Update von SA rausgekommen
indem wir eine Menge Feedback von euch
in die App haben einfließen lassen was
sich genau alles geändert hat erfahrt
ihr gleich jetzt aber erstmal die
neueste Version von SAV runterladen und
natürlich den Creator Code save auswähen
für die Leute die gar nicht wissen
worüber ich rede es gibt schon fünf
Videos in denen ich den Startup Aufbau
begleitet habe kurzer Abriss eine
Cashback App gegründet mit der wir
Nummer 1 sparapp in Deutschland werden
wollen und was soll ich sagen wir sind
auf einem ziemlich guten Weg daher
zurück zum apprase ihr könnt uns glauben
uns ist ein riesiger Stein vom Herzen
gefallen als wir gemerkt haben dass es
direkt eigentlich alles funktioniert und
wir haben auch gefeiert und zwar genau
einen Tag weil danach ging die Arbeit
erst so richtig man kann es so ein
bisschen mit einem selbstgebauten
Kartenhaus vergleichen man bastelt die
ganze Zeit da dran hofft dass es
irgendwie stehen bleibt und zum Release
zieht man die Hände weg und guckt dann
ob es tatsächlich funktioniert und ja es
funktioniert das Kartenhaus bleibt
stehen aber so richtig kann man den
Braten noch nicht trauen und gerade weil
der Ansturm so groß war hat es uns im
Support vor allem in den Tagen nach dem
Release wirklich an die Grenzen gebracht
so sehr dass wir unser Team aufstocken
mussten nicht nur auf Supportseite
sondern auch an Coder und salesfront im
Prinzip überall und wir haben auch
überall richtig gute passende Leute
gefunden mittlerweile arbeiten wir mit
sieben Leuten voll Zeit an dem Projekt
und da setät ich mich noch nicht mal
rein und das ist schon wirklich verrückt
nicht nur weil wir ein sehr junges
Unternehmen sind sondern weil
gleichzeitig jetzt auch die Aufgaben von
dem managen all dieser Leute und
Angestellten mit dazu kommt also es gibt
wirklich an allen Seiten richtig viel zu
tun und während sich die App mit all
ihren Funktionen und Features im
Hintergrund immer weiter entwickelt so
entwickelt sich auch der Workflow
unseres Teams immer weiter man muss sich
vorstellen ich kannte die Jungs nicht
und die Jungs kannten mich nicht
bedeutet wir wussten auch überhaupt
nicht wie irgend jemand von uns arbeitet
in einer Sache waren wir uns aber von
vorne rein natürlich 100% sicher gerade
weil wir örtlich in Deutschland so weit
voneinander entfernt sind haben wir
keine Lust auf Papierkram auf das
Drucken auf das Scannen und erst recht
nicht auf das Versenden von Dokumenten
per Post genau deswegen sind wir
unendlich happy Adobe Acrobat zu nutzen
die Zeit ist nämlich längst vorbei bei
der man für die Änderung von
irgendwelchen Dokumenten irgendwelche
shady Websites benutzen muss Adobe
Acrobat ist nämlich die perfekte
Symbiose aus allem was man zum Arbeiten
braucht völlig egal ob PDFs kommentier
zusammenfügen bearbeiten oder auch
unterschreiben wirklich es macht alles
so viel einfacher am Ende sind wir alle
Internet Kids native Internet User warum
also auch nicht all diese Vorteile für
unsere Arbeit nutzen besonders dann wenn
wir örtlich sow weit voneinander
getrennt sind und sich Homeoffice immer
weiter normalisiert besonders während
der Anfangszeit kann man sich vorstellen
haben wir unheimlich viel Kram hin und
her geschickt mediaakits Logoentwürfe
Vertragsentwürfe und all die wollen
kommentiert bearbeitet und ausgefeilt
werden ich will mir gar nicht vorstellen
wie lange das gedauert hätte wenn wir es
postalisch mit papierkramm gemacht
hätten oder ob es überhaupt funktioniert
hätte und wir jetzt da wären wo wir sind
mein Favorite Feature mit Abstand ist
das digitale unterschreiben endlich
keinen ausdrucken unterschreiben und
einscannen mehr was einfach nur nervt
und völlig unnötig ist macht also jetzt
auch euren Workflow endlich komplett
papierlos und das mit der Testversion
von Adobe Acrobat die über den ersten
Link in der Videobeschreibung findet
vielen Dank an Adobe Acrobat für die
Unterstützung und euch viel Spaß weiter
mit dem
Video jeder von euch kennt aber die
Annahme habe ich die Sache geschafft
habe ich endlich ein bisschen mehr Ruhe
und jeder von euch weiß auch dass es
genauso nie ist hat man die eine Sache
geschafft stehen schon die nächsten drei
und bei savit gefühlt die nächsten fünf
direkt vor der Tür wir haben also den
Arsch voll Arbeit am Ende soll die App
aber natürlich genau den Zweck erfüllen
den ihr also die Zielgruppe möchte also
haben wir uns euer Feedback zu Herzen
genommen und eine Menge neuer Features
eingebaut seit heute ist es möglich
verschiedene Creator gleichzeitig zu
unterstützen falls ihr euch nicht
entscheiden könnt oder wollt und das
erste Mal auch nicht nur Creator sondern
auch NGOs Projekte und lokale
Initiativen worüber wir mega happy sind
weil wir das Feld an zu unterstützenden
Personen und Projekten mega krass
ausweisen bedeutet ihr kauft ein wie ihr
es gewohnt seid unterstützt aber
gleichzeitig eure lieblingsngos und
müsst gleichzeitig nicht darauf
verzichten auch noch euren lieblings
Creator zu unterstützen oder mehrere
NGOs und Projekte gleichzeitig damit
gibt's mehr Möglichkeiten für euch und
mehr Unterstützung für alle außerdem
eine Menge Usability Themen die es
deutlich einfacher machen die App zu
benutzen und in der App zu navigieren
wie z.B in den iOS wiback ihr wischt
also einfach zurück müsst nicht extra
auf den zurückknopf drücken und es wird
deutlich smoother die App zu benutzen
und außerdem eine Menge Möglichkeiten
die App weiter zu personalisieren wie
z.B das favorisieren von Shops um die
App so zu gestalten wie ihr sie gerne
haben möchtet und gleichzeitig be all
eurureen Lieblingsshops up to date zu
bleiben aber es lief auch nicht alles
glatt und wir hatten natürlich auch ein
paar kleinere Probleme z.B haben die
Supportanfragen am Anfang deutlich
länger gedauert als wir es uns gewünscht
hätten das ist mittlerweile alles
geklärt wir haben das Supportteam
aufgestockt und im Hintergrund den
Mechanismus so gebaut dass wir euch
deutlich schneller mit Rat und Tat zur
Seite stehen können eine der meist
gestellten Fragen über die
Supporttickets war warum kann ich mein
Cashback noch nicht auszahlen und die
Antwort ist ganz einfach die Shops
warten alle Rückgabefristen und
irgendwelche anderen Fristen ab bevor
sie dann eure Transaktion euer Cashback
noch mal manuell freigeben müssen dieser
Prozess kann bis zu 120 Tagen dauern und
bevor diese 120 Tage nicht vergangen
sind bekommen wir das Geld nicht um es
euch auszuzahlen mittlerweile sollten
wir aber in einem Zyklus sein wo das
alles smooth läuft und wir arbeiten auch
mit vielen Shops aner löse damit das
alles deutlich schneller geht aber wir
können einfach kein Geld auszahlen was
wir noch nicht haben und sind dabei auf
die Arbeit und auf die Schnelligkeit der
Shops angewiesen aber nicht nur neue
Leute die eingearbeitet werden mussten
neue Features Probleme die gelöst werden
mussten nein ich habe ja auch in dem
Video nach Investoren gefragt weil wir
Geld brauchten das dachten wir zumindest
erstmal auch vielen Dank für all die
investorenanfragen die wir bekommen
haben das ist unglaublich wen man alles
mit diesen Videos erreicht es haben sich
wirklich eine Menge Leute gemeldet wir
haben aber relativ schnell gemerkt dass
wir von Tag 1 rentabel sind und dass
sich das Unternehmen trägt wir alles
zahlen können und alles bestens läuft
haben deswegen vorerst darauf verzichtet
von Investoren weiteres Geld anzunehmen
es gibt aber unheimlich viele sehr
interessante Anfragen W mit großen
Firmen gesprochen jeder von euch kennt
über gemeinsame features
appintegration also wirklich eine Menge
Menge cooler Kram und es gibt sogar
konkretes Kaufinteresse von mehreren
Leuten die uns gerne komplett kaufen
würden wie es da weitergeht was alles an
neuen Features kommt potentielle
kommende Investoren appintegration und
so weiter kann ich im jetzigen Status
leider noch nichts zu sagen weil wir
Angst davor haben uns selber Steine in
den Weg zu legen wir wollen einfach
nichts vorwegnehmen gerade weil wir in
den letzten Monaten gemerkt haben dass
wir absolut den richtigen Riecher hatten
auf dem richtigen Weg sind und
vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen
früher dran sind als einige andere in
den letzten Monaten haben nämlich einige
große Firmen irgendeine Art von Cashback
Integration angekündigt und deswegen
müssen wir Stillschweigen bewahren und
erstmal an unserem Tool weiterbauen
alles in allem aber natürlich sehr cool
zu sehen das in großen Firmen wo weiß
ich nicht wie viel hundert Leute an
irgendwelchen neuen Features Arbeiten
einen Schritt in dieselbe Richtung gehen
weil das eine absolute Bestätigung für
unser Tool und für unsere Richtung ist
alles schön und gut aber was bedeutet
das zahlenaten faktenmäßig was ist in
den letzten drei Monaten schwarz auf
weiß passiert ihr wisst ja schon wir
hatten den erfolgreichsten App Launch
Deutschlands jemals nach 6 Stunden schon
100.000 Nutzer nach 72 Stunden 200.000
nutzerv voll und jetzt knapp 3 Monate
später stehen wir bei über 350.000
Nutzern worauf wir mächtig stolz sind
und was ein unglaublicher wirklich
phänomenaler Start ist womit wir niemals
gerechnet hätten unser Ziel waren
100.000 Nutzer bis zum Ende des Jahres
dass wir zum Ende des Jahres dann 300
oder so bisschen über 300.000 Nutzer
hatten ist völlig verrückt und abseits
von den Nutzerzahlen die App im App
Store und im PlayStore über Tage hinweg
auf Platz 1 vor Instagram temu und
anderen Riesen zu sehen war einfach
unglaublich also hier noch mal ein
riesen Dankeschön an jeden der uns den
Start so zuckerüß gemacht hat sagt man
das so keine Ahnung zuckerüß neben euch
den Nutzern haben sich aber auch über
3000 Creator beworben was eine Masse war
mit der wir niemals gerechnet hätten und
die wir in Handarbeit bis heute noch
nicht durchgearbeitet haben obwohl wir
die ganze Zeit daran arbeiten ihr müsst
euch vorstellen wir wollen sicher gehen
dass die Leute die sich mit einem
Account als Creator bewerben auch
wirklich die Creator sind bedeutet wir
müssen in Handarbeit jeden einzelnen
durchgehen alles checken und am Ende
wollen wir sicher gehen dass die Leute
die wir euch als Creator auf der
Plattform Anzeigen echt sind keine
Scheiße bauen und dort einfach alles
clean läuft also falls ihr ein Creator
seid der immer noch auf Bestätigung
wartet seht es uns nach wir arbeiten
weiter daran und schalten euch alle nach
und nach frei und ein sehr schönes
Beispiel für die Nutzung von SAV it von
creatorn ist Sascha der angekündigt hat
ein Renault tezy zu verlosen und ich
glaube nach knapp zwei Monaten die Kohle
dafür voll hatte wir bleiben gespannt
wer den twezy gewinnt und ich hoffe
dabei sein zu können jetzt aber zum
wirklich interessanten Punkt wie viel
konnten die Nutzer in den ersten drei
Monaten von Savage sparen und das ist
völlig verrückt einige Nutzer haben
alleine über 1000 oder 2000 € gespart
ich denke weil sie Geschäftsreisen oder
so darüber gebucht haben was wirklich
völlig verrückt ist und gerade bei
solchen großen Umsätzen also bucht man
häufig Reisen fürs Geschäft oder bucht
man Reise für den Sommer oder kauft man
Weihnachtsgeschenke dann lässt sich
richtig Kohle sparen insgesamt haben
sich die Nutzer in den ersten drei
Monaten über 350.000 € mit SAV it an
Cashback erspart was völlig verrückt ist
weil da noch keine Auszahlung an Creator
und und so weiter dabei ist und an
Außenumsatz also Geld was überb save it
in anderen Shops ausgegeben wurde sehen
die Zahlen noch mal völlig verrückt aus
als kleines Beispiel ohne dass wir eine
große Aktion an Black Friday gefahren
haben wurde über save it in Shops über
500.000 € Umsatz gemacht die Zahlen die
wir da drehen sind also wirklich völlig
verrückt und gerade das Feedback der
Shops ist unglaublich natürlich kann ich
keine Zahlen von irgendwelchen anderen
creatorn veröffentlichen aber als
kleines Beispiel ich selber konnte über
meinen Creator Code im Dezember ohne
eine Youtube Integration über 20 000 €
einnehmen was richtig verrückt ist alles
in allem sind wir mega happy auch wenn
wir uns seit Monaten wirklich an der
maximalen Kapazitätsgrenze bewegen und
einfach nicht mehr arbeiten können es
hätte aber nicht besser laufen können
vielen Dank noch mal an jeden und sorry
dass ich euch nicht in weitere große
Pläne einweihen kann weil ich Angst habe
dass wir uns sonst selber Steine in den
Weg legen nächste Woche geht's direkt
weiter mit der nächsten Folge zuur
Autovermietung vergesst also nicht den
Kanal zu abonnieren wenn ihr das und
alle weiteren Updates zu SAV nicht
verpassen wollt vielen Dank fürs Zhen
macht's
[Musik]
gut